thanks to all the fans who made our
first theatrical premiere of one of our
reviews a huge hit we had giveaway
signings a QA and of course a review on
the big screen we're sure to do more in
the future and until then here's a sneak
thief it is the true or new film from DC
what do we call what a next Superman
come to take us out game similar to the
war guardians of the galaxy you're going
to take down the next Superman with a
boomerang hello I'm the Nostalgia guy
remember it so you don't have to despite
it being a big hit this movie divided a
lot of audio hey I worked hard to find
the worst of the worst and you came
across boomerangs malice guns a petting
zoo and a guy who makes fire who no
longer makes fire soon the whole world
about my Mersey what just the way that I
could this is the part where you have to
feel defeated at Busch ah the bad guys
are supposed to push out jiggy
don't say jiggy I literally invented
jiggy Jerry what Oh
I can't wait to show you my toys we're
not gonna see the more we know that
seems been cut as well as this of course
you finished yeah I'm finished you feel
better yeah
[Music]
well I care what someone even like a bad
bet it was tougher than I thought Excel
we fiddled that dizzle for shizzle my
bizzle are you seriously telling you
that supervillain to do less harm than
Superman did you participate metropolis
look after Superman saves it from Jean
tokm bad god how many times I have to
say this damn movie
just give us a good DC
[Music]
hey everybody Doug Walker Here I am
doing my first ever trailer reaction
never done these before if I see
everybody doing it so I really wanted to
do one and so I'm finally doing one for
the nostalgia critic review of Suicide
Squad now you might be thinking that's a
little conflict of interest because you
know I did the review and I literally
just got done making this trailer but
the thing about that is I am drunk
beyond any realm of believability and I
can't remember what I just did
I'm not even sure that's what I'm going
to watch right now so I'm just gonna try
and do this like any other trailer you
know I'm just going to try and predict
what's going to happen and you know see
if it looks good and stuff like that
because everybody does if they watch it
and you know they immediately review it
so that's what I'm going to do I'm going
to review my own trailer and trying to
get a feel whether or not this is going
to be a good review so here we go hope
it's good
sorry that's immediately wrong that does
not represent nostalgia critic at all
you know the fact that starts with a
building and not the nostalgia create
that that's just not was about hopefully
it's very sound the next Superman with a
boomerang channel awesome ok if the
logos there that's good that is good it
shows fast you know a company made it we
could Pont a lot okay now this is the
part where I just stare blankly a heads
of screaming I'm kind of shocked people
are entertained by that but but that's
what I'm gonna do
just like that that was good
they say that that's a good part I like
that that that's really funny are
supposed to push jiggy-jiggy
I literally know now that that's the
treasure right there I said just I'm not
I'm not pressed by that guy's not
blowing me away is not blowing me away
at all wait to show you my toys
we're not going to see the look that
part I like this is guys very good this
is gonna be really super risky good okay
now this is the part where the video
gets taken down because of some studio
assholes doing a copyright claim
okay we're past that wonderful we're
back all right
so in case you missed it um this is
amazing but awful at the same time but
it's not amazingly awful I like that
there are clips it's very clever
this trailer knows to do that at least I
like that a lot
are you seriously tell you're going to
the left arm to the man did you / - come
to good use of clips from the thing I'm
going to see from the thing it's
advertising how many times there's a
sailor's damn movie
[Music]
okay um yeah this is the part where I
sit here probably way too long just
really taking it all in
um I mean that's just that that it is
what it is uh I mean the great thing
about it about me seeing it is that just
from that couple of minutes I can tell
you exactly what it's going to be
because it's going to be one of three
things it's either going to be the worst
goddamn thing ever made by human beings
the greatest thing we as a species have
ever put together or it's going to be
okay it is definitely one of those three
so it's a good thing you watch this it's
a good thing you saw my reaction to this
I see why these videos do very well you
get a lot of insight watching trailers I
bet now it's like I didn't get before if
I'm really putting it together now okay
alright now this is usually the part
where I overthink something some part
I'm just going to go to like a you know
something I thought I saw and I'm just
going to like really zoom in on it okay
here we go that's the that's the chart
guide to their boat shark guides okay so
we know the chart guys are in this we
know that all right so that's that's big
I'm going to do probably another video
that has like this thumbnail and an
arrow pointing at something it doesn't
matter what it is that you just see the
arrow you're like whoa that's something
that I gotta click on this so I'm
probably going to point at that hat the
one that says I heart charge uh because
I think that is a definite clue that
that's the chart guy and especially
since the chart says yeah
that um it confirmed the chart guys are
in this I don't know what to make of
that I don't like it seems like it'd be
a good thing but it also seems like it'd
be a bad thing or maybe it doesn't
really make a difference either way so
take that from this okay alright well
that is my first a trailer reaction to
my own trailer uh you know a lot of
speculation what's going to be in it I
mean I know I made it I know I made both
the review and the trailer but um I
think I'm going to be pretty surprised
when I see this even though I just
predicted what it's going to be either
the greatest thing ever the worst thing
ever or okay so again it's a good thing
you clicked on this to see my reaction
to this trailer so um yeah I get it now
I get I know why people do this if you
excuse me I'm gonna puke into a toilet
you said I'm drunk but I think is the
best video I ever did since so let's
play it Birds a nightmare I got a drink
more yeah now a genius way to do that
hey okay reel me this time no alcohol or
anything once again doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Bob Woodward foundation this is for
helping veterans with face serious
injury as well as their families combat
injuries present very real and
complicated new reality but our nation's
injured veterans and their families are
not broken they are relentless and
determined to once again lead meaningful
lives through their charitable
investment program they diligently
navigate a broad range of nonprofits to
find the most innovative programs
meeting the needs of today's veterans
they look for diversity and program
focus organization type and geographic
location and so through diligence and a
commitment to meeting the highest of
standards the Bob Woodruff foundation
invests in high-impact programs and
resources that ensure success ded States
by collaborating with government private
and public organizations they're able to
influence the best programs and
resources and improve upon helping build
rehabilitation and recovery education
and employment and of course quality of
life if you look at their site or their
YouTube page you can see how you can
help these people on their mission and
deliver these veterans what they deserve
click on the link check them out and see
how you too can help say thanks for all
that they've done
you